Republican Senate majority leader Mitch McConnell
has admitted that Donald Trump will effectively
get to direct his own impeachment trial in
the Senate to catch you up.
Things are moving in the direction of an impeachment
trial in the Senate against president Donald
Trump likely to be impeached by the full house
any day now, maybe already by the time you
get today's show, maybe later this week, the
trial in the Senate is likely to happen in
January.
It's going to be managed by the Senate majority
leader who's a Republican, Mitch McConnell.
And it will then be presided over by the chief
justice of the Supreme court.
That's John Roberts, also a conservative justice.
Mitch McConnell has pledged quote, total cord
and nation with the white house.
He said this of course on Fox news while being
interviewed naturally by propagandist, Sean
Hannity.
Take a look.
We'll listen to the opening, uh,
arguments by the house prosecutors and will
listen to the president's lawyers, uh, respond
and then we'll have to make a decision about
the way forward and everything I do during
this, I'm coordinating with white house council.
There will be no difference between the president's
position and our position as to how to handle
this.
Uh, to the extent that we can, we don't have
the kind of ball control on this that a typical
issue, for example, comes over to the house.
If, if I don't like it, we don't egg it up.
We have no choice but to take it up.
But we'll be working through this process
hopefully in a fairly short period of time.
In total coordination, uh, with the white
house counsel's office and the people who
are representing the president in the oil
of the Senate.
There is no difference between the white house
and the Senate on this issue.
Remember that it was Republicans attacking
the house proceedings in the impeachment inquiry
for being a kangaroo court.
They are admitting that the guy who is in
practice, the foreman of the jury, that's
sort of what Mitch McConnell is, has already
decided on the verdict before the trial has
started.
They have been talking about the impeachment
process is rigged.
It seems they are rigging it in the Senate.
The usual projection, what they accuse others
of they themselves are doing.
This is not normal quote.
According to the rules expressed in the constitution
during an impeachment trial of the president
of the United States, the Senate takes an
oath to act as impartial jurors.
McConnell has already said he won't be impartial.
He has prejudged the verdict.
He said he will coordinate with the accused.
The Senate is supposed to be the jury.
Imagine if in a criminal trial the foreman
of the jury was coordinating with the defendant.
That's what we're talking about here.
The framers of the constitution set up some
safeguards like for example, saying that in
an impeachment trial the Senate must function
as a nonpartisan jury.
They never imagined that we'd have a president
this corrupt and a Senate majority leader
this willing to prop up the president's corruption.
We often say when they wrote the second amendment,
they couldn't imagine fully automatic rifles.
When they set up the checks and balances.
Clearly they couldn't imagine a president
this brazen and ignoring the rule of law and
this corrupt combined with the Senate that
is so willing to shield and protect that same
president and engage in dereliction of their
duty.
Does this feel sort of wrong to anybody else?
Is anybody else concerned about what's going
on?
But remember, if you are, we knew this was
going to happen.
I'm endlessly surprised by how bold and brazen
and shameless they are about it, but we knew
from the start the Senate will equip.
We knew this ahead of time.
They are now saying it out loud, which is
we don't care about the trial.
We don't care about the facts.
We are going to acquit and we let the white
house tell us how to run this thing for whatever
Donald Trump perceived to be his maximum benefit.
There are whispers that Donald Trump has been
suggesting that he wants the trial to drag
out as long as possible and that he believes
that will be the best thing for him.
So eventually the trial will end.
We'll wake up and realize we don't really
have a democracy here.
Not in any real sense.
We don't have checks and balances that still
have clout because the president has been
able to get away with ignoring them and then
hopefully we will vote in large enough numbers
in 2020 to overwhelm voter suppression, gerrymandering,
foreign influence, the propaganda and remove
the sky.
That's the hope that we overwhelm all of those
structural disadvantages in November of 2020
I see that as the only possible path forward
and every day that is becoming clearer and
clearer.
Particularly now that we've heard from Mitch
McConnell on January 1st we're getting ready
to start the new year on January 1st we will
have a massive election year membership special.
If you've been thinking of becoming a member
and supporting this show, that is of course
the number one funding source for the show.
January one is the day to do it.
We're going to have a major membership special.
It's going to be obscene, quite frankly.
How do you get notified?
Just get on our newsletter, go to David pakman.com
uh, upper right corner of the website.
It says, sign up for the mailing list.
Get on that newsletter mailing list, and on
January one you will receive just an, it's
obscene.
I, our lawyers have told me that, don't even
mention it because it's so disgusting what
we're going to be offering on January one
follow me on Twitter at the Pacman.
Let me know what you think about Mitch McConnell
and we'll be back right after this